hey what is up guys I'm so excited cuz
it's a very first episode of hey okay so
I know right now you're hearing a lot of
voices and you don't know who the [ __ ]
we are or who's saying what so we're
gonna start it really slow smooth and
sexy okay okay so I'm going to start
from my left can you please introduce
yourself and we'll work our way down
okay there's six of us right now yeah I
know like what level of introduction is
like like your name for one we can go
with your name and um Bo's okay okay so
we got both next to Bo's we got hey it's
Gina okay and then the person talked to
you with the sexiest voice right now is
myself Gio I mean I am Nikki Li mo oh if
you're watching us on YouTube you can
see all of our faces yeah and then it's
not completely stupid
I'm Tiffany nice to meet you and then
the last person not the least though
definitely not legally not definitely
Jessica oh you go by Jessica yes you can
call me Jess but we all call you Jess
yeah just say Jess yeah so we want to
scratch the whole jessica thing and
we're just gonna do well jessica is what
I'm like really feeling myself
Sasha Fierce okay Jessica for now Cole
is like oh so for those of you that know
who we are
hi and thanks for supporting hey badge
um but for those of you that don't know
who we are we are literally a group of
friends like we are legit friends yeah
like just pretend no we're not literally
I'm talking like group chat at 4 a.m.
friends yeah yeah it really like send
our nudes to each other and say can I
send this yeah that's how this started
actually we were in a chat a group chat
on Instagram called host base and we
found out that like through sharing our
different stories about different topics
like one person will bring up a topic
and then bunch people would put their
import tab we'll give me an example um
let's say dick size okay
yeah so like we would be some
would be like hey I'm dating this guy is
it's too small yeah yeah there's a lot
and also it's like a total application
process because one day I'm on set at JK
and I heard geo talking about this group
and I was like oh yeah can I get an
invite and she's like very protective of
my circle oh yeah I love my girls and
I'm like I'm trying to protect from all
evil yeah because the [ __ ] that goes
down in that chat uh-huh we can't just
be like no okay I know we're being super
vague okay so we will talk like what
Nikki was saying about like the dick
size right so we'll go into the stick
conversation and all of us start chiming
in and we're like very supportive and
then like ten minutes later someone
comes in is like dude I [ __ ] had the
biggest fight with my man right now like
we're just on the rocks like what's
gonna happen and then we all start like
giving all this personal information of
like dude you know things that worked
for three years ago like you know I like
you know I caught him like looking at
porn or whatever night that we just
cried and oh my god meet you and then it
goes right back to oh my god look at
this guys [ __ ] fine it's fall it also
goes into like one person will come in
and be like guys I have like this job of
a blonde like super nervous about it
what I do we're giving like business
advice and [ __ ] that's that saying we
have everything in there and that's what
basically I think this podcast is gonna
be I feel really supported and I feel
like we were all missing that so bring
it to a podcast I'm sure there's so many
people out there right now that feel
like they don't have that yet so we're
gonna be that for you okay we are your
older sister your mentor your yeah you
guys are you right and you don't got to
be a girl to listen to this we got some
guy advice - yeah I'm gonna be your big
sister - and your side chicks or if you
and your wingman we're gonna be your
wingman you're a dude that's like I
wonder what girls actually think we're
just gonna give it to you raw yes okay I
like to do it dogging I do want to go
back to oh yeah I do want to go back
into the solo talk real quick and we'll
start again I hate going in order like
this but I'm gonna do it just for the
sake of simplicity oh my gosh okay Jess
you're gonna go for origin story origin
story you're gonna talk about what you
did before you came into the space
the podcast base so you can talk about
where you were what brought you into
YouTube that led you into this ok how
many how many minutes should I try to
find out if I'm talking too much okay
like the Grammys song you're talking too
much
yeah I'm just gonna pull the [ __ ] mic
side okay let's see where do I start
um so I started before I did YouTube I
was an accountant we're in San Antonio
Texas okay I was actually an auditor
I've been in order for like four years
or something so I got my masters and I
did I went that route business route
okay I didn't finish my associates right
I should be on a t-shirt for you brains
beauty and a booty hmm oh but a lot of
people are like I guess for a white girl
she has booty but not enough are you
going to Hooters well getting your
masters yes oh my god you're like that
stripper story except I still have a dad
so okay so don't mean you can't feel
excluded
I got you Nicki we're good okay so you
get your masters you're working as an
auditor yeah and then uh over time I
just realized it was boring his [ __ ] it
wasn't what I how long did you do it for
it was about four years okay so I went
from being like a staff into a senior
like I got promoted as making more money
it was all good but it was like this is
really my life it was pretty boring
dammm she had a master Oh
they're sexy are a right turning boson
girl job you want to meet up later mode
we going to the table can we [ __ ] will
you hug your diploma like so basic
though to have a master's in business
come on yeah yeah okay and then so I met
Joe online JK just kidding films yeah on
Instagram and we started dating long
distance can I see what you told them
the line that he tells us because he
likes to make it as if it was the first
thing I [ __ ] told him yeah it was a
down a bit we were talking for like a
month just texting back and forth and
then eventually I was kind of like
trying to get him to come see me and so
I said some line about you can come to
Texas we've got you know some barbecue
and we can [ __ ] and [ __ ] who slid into
whose DMS first so I was following him
on Instagram as like a fan I guess and
then I just I wasn't even on my radar
gotta start with the come-up story like
the greatest come up story of all time
oh my oh so you're telling me that if I
send enough nudes the Michael B Jordan
know it might work I didn't send any
news okay let me know so Joe so I think
I probably commented like once or twice
he did she slid in it commented on you
know using as a public figure no I was
not even attracted to Joe oh I've seen
Joe he slid into the dams asking about
my dog Maddie because she kind of looks
like a Shiba but she's like huge so
she's not a she moment he's like is that
a Shiba and I'm like no and then we just
kept talking how do you saw how did you
feel when you saw Joe Jitsu Kawa sent
you a message on it what's that Joe Joe
Joe Joe yeah yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
this is a youtuber that I've seen like
oh that's crazy yeah I wasn't like oh my
god I want to [ __ ] him yeah yeah I fell
first personality okay we've seen Joe we
know just like a Bobby I love Joe oh
yeah okay so after that then yeah so we
dated for a year and then he just kind
of inspired me to be like well my life's
not over and if I'm not happy with the
job I'm doing I can take a break from it
I can come back to it in the future I
can just quit it forever and then you
know I was gonna resize my lease in
Austin and he was like how about you
just come out to LA so like I decided to
just [ __ ] all of it and move here it's
amazing yeah it's been hard though
because it's definitely a super
transition and like I never wanted to be
an entertainment but you have a masters
you can I feel like you can feel like
anything doesn't matter like breath over
your stinking master's and no student
loans you know be successful we don't
got that I'm gonna be doing this ad read
later so you guys paid good attention
[Laughter]
okay so then so he proceeded he
persuades you to move in with him and
then what happens how did you end up in
YouTube well he's a youtuber and I
wasn't working anymore cuz I just said
[ __ ] it to my job in my career and then
so I just started showing up like
vlogging with him and then eventually he
just had me like show up for some JK
film stuff but yeah it's been a slow
burn on the whole entertainment thing
cuz I know that you're still like kind
of holding back a little bit trying to
figure if you want to and then this is
the year that you started yeah I was
like I guess I'm here like I've been in
LA for like four years now and I haven't
really tried at all I've just been like
I guess I'll show up and then I'm on set
and I'm like I don't like it I'm scared
so I don't really push myself into the
whole being seen things so I don't know
I like privacy and I'm scared of like
being in front of the camera but I'm
getting better but you're literally on a
podcast I know I don't know how you got
here like how did
get here I don't know I'm just here what
was the point where you're like [ __ ] it
like I'm just gonna do it and I'm gonna
commit to it I think it was around New
Year's this year or like December last
year I was kind of like I'm just gonna
give it a hundred percent this year and
if it still doesn't feel like it's going
in a great direction then I can just go
back to my career or like try something
else because I just felt like I was in a
kind of in a middle zone like one foot
in one foot out I'm not really trying so
I'm not really getting anywhere not
seeing any results from any direction so
I was like well I got to just push 100%
that's really rad though because you
have the luxury of having both sides
like you really want to go back to
corporate 95 you have that master's
degree that Bose loves yeah yeah and if
he decides and if you decide to go into
entertainment you have like the whole
crew here that you can work off of -
yeah luxury of both sides yeah awesome
it is a good place to be and I think I
wasn't appreciating my situation enough
so I decided to try to appreciate it a
little bit more and like jump in a
little bit harder that's powerful [ __ ]
yeah in love with you right now
okay guys TIFF yeah about you me before
YouTube I was working at a hospital so
like completely different
I had gone to like technical school
things I was working with surgical
instruments not really with patients but
why did you go into that field before
even go into that before so I was a
single mom and I needed to have like
figure out how to have a career really
quickly and just get my life put
together for my son and so that was the
easiest quickest thing I could do yeah
and so yeah it's I ended up just I think
I worked at the hospital maybe about
five years four or five years and so
during that time was when I met Casey
and then I met Jake hey cuz Casey was he
was like directing the skits at JK was
filming and yeah while I was dating him
everyone was just like come on we need
another girl for the skit so I'm like ah
[ __ ] I'm so camera shy I'm like this
squeaky little mouse like I can't even
project my voice and you had braces in
classes I did yeah
at 21 like yeah yeah so I was just like
I had them at 15 by the way okay hey my
beers well let's head gear me too didn't
I tell you oh look yeah do you see this
overbite yeah like either I have to get
braces at my age or like headgear for 12
hours a day I will and yo yours yeah I
wore mine at night only you said you
know I was talking about right now
yes right I'll get it wait you about to
get headgear now possibly ya know if you
send your man a nude with headgear on I
want so much you have a thing you a nude
with I'm gonna own that [ __ ] just how
sorry but would you rather get braces at
my age or a headgear for six months
while races like you I'd rather do that
it's an overbite it's an overbite sorry
sorry tip sorry okay all right well
before we even start on that we're gonna
take a quick commercial break
hey what's up guys okay wait I already
said hey all right so special thanks to
third love for sponsoring this video
for those of you ladies that can't find
your perfect bra third love is the bra
for you let me tell you I never knew how
to buy a bra like I didn't have anyone
guide me through the bra buying process
I had like a Cubs but I was wearing a
c-cup and like this [ __ ] was just like
for my dreams you had a dream I don't
know why I thought that fit and it like
it gave me like like mini Peaks and I
was like okay that's cool but then I'd
bend over and you can see like
everything I didn't know anything and
then I go and [ __ ] it all up even more
and I go to Victoria's Secret and then I
mean I don't what am I talking about
I go and I [ __ ] it up even more by
getting breast augmentation and now I
really don't know what my bra size is so
I have like 13 different bras and I
literally like one might fit me okay
like my boobs are spilling all over the
place I'm actually asymmetrical is what
I found out so those people are this big
goods yeah I do
not perfect after all all right
love is tight because you go on their
website and then you take this 30 second
like questionnaire and it's just all
picture so that they go okay what are
your boobs kind of look like and then
you're looking at all these boobs
they're drawn so they're not like real
live boobs boobs yeah so you're looking
at it and you're like oh I think mine
kind of look like this I'm like okay
well how do you want like were your
problem areas in your boobs and for me
I'm like well my tits are always
spilling out and I'm like it's always
hurting my shoulders and then after 30
seconds they find you your perfect bra
and I'm like dude this is [ __ ] this
is not perfect so I go I check out I buy
it I end up recommending their t-shirt
bra I get it I'm literally wearing that
bra right now I'm wearing out their love
brow right now that's who are you really
the best bra ever Italy it's amazing
yeah like you can't see any bra lines my
boob some fur ball it is there it's not
spilling over you don't see nipple äj--
I absolutely love it they have a lot of
in between sizes too so you're gonna
find the perfect fit this was a company
made by a woman so I mean who knows a
woman's body better than a woman but
doesn't give you that back fat thing too
you know that's that's what I always
have a problem with was with the band
giving you like a back fat bulge it
doesn't do that and also the straps or
don't like dig yeah like it has this
like little ridges cute and then ladies
of your concern from a man's point of
view I give those breasts
two thumbs up yeah these are bought but
thank you thank you so for all our
listeners their LIF knows that there's a
perfect bra for everyone so right now
they are offering our listeners 15% off
your order so go to thir live.com /a b
tch now to find your perfect fitting bra
and get 50% off your first purchase
that's third love.com slash b tch for
15% off today yes and we are back so
TIFF yes
take it away yeah so just working with
JK it was a really really hard thing for
me to do because I was definitely in my
shell like I just did not want to be
seen at all and but yeah it kind of
really forced me to just say suck it the
[ __ ] up and being this [ __ ] skit and
try to protect your voice when you're on
use and all that stuff so yeah they
eventually led to me now hosting JK news
you've come a long way girl both of you
not wanting to be an entertainment and
like ending up an entertainment that's
that's crazy what most people are like
planning to be an entertainment or just
like no but we're still here [ __ ]
that's not like natural performer that
doesn't has never had that instinct to
go and become a performer that's like a
huge step yeah you know it's funny I
don't ever see myself as an entertainer
performer I'm just like I'm just here
and I'm just being me and there just so
happens to be a camera not like now I've
learned to forget that there's a camera
yeah because in the beginning it was the
hardest thing ever I'm like oh this is
scary Lynn staring at me there's like
thousands of people being named in red
light that's watching and it's just
scary so I just try not to even think
about or else I'm really gonna get into
my head but uh but yeah and then just oh
and so like Casey and I always started
our own family channel with my son I got
plug it what is it what's called tiffin
case okay and we mainly now just tend to
travel vlog we don't really do a lot of
at-home stuff but every year we're like
we gotta get some more out there like
we're now like we don't really play the
YouTube game because it's same as Casey
he's never really wanted to be in front
of the camera either and somehow we
ended up in front of the camera and so
we're just kind of like we gotta just
make the best out of it and yeah so
we're just trying to push it through and
but I'm so glad that I met Casey and I
met JK because it's led to like the
greatest group of friends I've ever had
in my life it's not even just friends
it's like spit and then like I was
trying to cover it up and it just made
it worse
so her she doesn't have a master's God
wait you don't have a master's you just
made me so self-conscious
my heart y'all are gonna see like this
moment of panic grumbling sorry dude
what happened she was [ __ ] building up
to the sweetest moment the entire
beautiful she was like saying this is
the best friend for a while I just
started salivating poking for
compliments you [ __ ] first up my life
no I was the middle saying how like I'm
so glad I met Casey JK and everyone cuz
it led me to the most amazing group of
friends that our family is serious [ __ ]
desertion no Pharrell but you know it's
funny we were picking stuff for the
decorations here in the set so if you're
watching on YouTube you know what I'm
talking about and I picked this tiny
little teal frame thing that says in
Spanish los Amigos on the phone me like
yes let's go ahead it would translate it
[ __ ] these girls something about my
family is my there you get to choose
they told me yesterday wait what is it
so your friends are the family that you
get to choose oh yeah I think so that's
pretty much mean and nutshell how I feel
about this group in your favorite color
- exactly and it's it's in gold - so
stealing gold
but yeah so I very beautiful I love I
love or I met in my life
because of the things that I've been
through it's really led me to a really
positive place so oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
alright we need those Craig glasses yeah
no I brought my Craig glasses
you don't know what the Krag glasses I
just found out about him wait and watch
the next episode where we explain
explain the car a grassy okay races it's
cried glasses other par first [ __ ] man
way to make me feel like Rygel asses
alright whenever we want to cry we go up
with some glass I don't know sorry the
next pot we're gonna boil oh no you guys
at the stake but look around yeah stick
around we have to and we're gonna pop
out a titty on the next one alright so
Nikki I know a lot about you but not
that I saw meat elegy so I'm excited to
hear what you got to say cuz you're like
looking everywhere all the time so tell
me about yourself I think important
thing is you well you guys need to know
that she got a badass ass first as 90%
ass the doctor was like lighter instead
of crying she was like don't look yeah
so I guess opposite of you guys I always
was an entertainer like I started acting
when I was 8 or 9 and I like books
commercials and was doing likes child
modeling and that kind of stuff and I
always wanted to be an actor moved to LA
in like 2008 and from where from Santa
Barbara but not that far I would before
that I was just commuting from Santa
Barbara to audition in LA Wow
yeah and so I was just auditioning and
being an actor and working as a waitress
to make to pay the bills and going
basically treated like my acting studio
as college cuz I dropped out of college
which my parents were really pissed
about because I had a full scholarship
no I
my dick my dick I was like nah I'm good
it was too thirsty yeah yeah yeah so I
found like a conservatory and like a
coach that had like celebrity clients
and just like used that as my College
because I feel like college should be to
prepare you for whatever career you're
gonna be and then I didn't find that at
the college so I was that like they
don't have good acting coaches at a
freaking college so and except you
unless you're going to anyway you or
somebody that but I wasn't so I came
here I was doing acting and I was not
making a living at it but I would book
girls here and there I was also doing
stand-up comedy
and I was working my ass off in my
acting classes and then got into YouTube
because I needed a demo reel and at that
time it was like people did not have
like high quality equipment like they it
was really shitty to try to do a demo
reel by yourself so yeah but I audition
audition I submitted for this one
channel that was just starting out they
had two videos up but their video
quality was really really good
they had like HD cameras and everything
was like you know looking legit and that
channel was totally sketch and they just
needed a girl and like you know
yeah well lack of girls and yeah comedy
sketches I first saw you oh I used to
watch Tony yes you remember when girls
that when I was on JK news she was like
I saw oh I didn't know who you were yeah
I don't know who you were oh yeah mix on
the tape yeah I got a show that my funny
is that back in 2012 three years into
YouTube already on totally sketch oh and
I was on this channel totally sketch but
I didn't really do anything on my own
channel so I was just an actor on
someone else's channel but during that
time when I was trying to launch my own
channel I was at full screen and they
told me they gave me a list of people to
collab with and JK films was on that
would have been so awesome
David so comedy I looked at that was the
other day I found like
notes like weird channel 12 like not
going to learn of these folks I actually
I didn't feel worthy because I was like
I don't really have anything to give
them I don't have like a channel that's
like poppin but I could act but I didn't
know that that was like a valuable thing
like I didn't know I had known you guys
he's a girl yeah I probably wouldn't
have been here oh [ __ ] yeah and so we
actually I met my husband through
totally sketch she was one of the
regular cast members there's five of us
and we were like the regular players on
there but we were both in serious
relationships and we were friends for
like four years
just like on camera together and like we
played boyfriend and girlfriend before
but we were never like it wasn't like
that we're both super loyal so I got to
see how he was in a relationship and he
got to see how I was in a relationship
and then we both got dumped at like the
same time and so then we were just like
crying together basically and then we
started dating so that now we're married
and that was like all from YouTube and
both of us found Jake oh my I guess I've
you guys reached out to me through Taryn
southern and I did a couple JK news
episodes and then like a year later you
guys saw my husband steve at tim rose
yeah he's not so good i talked about him
a lot and asked the feels in like JK
news episodes but i had never you guys
had never met him yeah and he did a
roast for tim delageteau and then you
guys had him on and the rest is history
so they're family now mm-hmm yeah so I
didn't I always wanted to be in front of
camera but I never thought it would be
like this like where I'm a personality
we look into the camera you're not
playing a character I never really
thought it would be that that was
something I really had to get used to
that was not natural to like pick up a
camera and look at it it's like crazy
complete opposite of acting training
yeah usually you hold it and make
someone else look at it yes no that's
not how it works in acting school wait
what do you mean like pick it up like
this you mean like a selfie what like
vlogging girl Oh
she doesn't have a masters she thinks
that I've been talking about being a
cinematographer of the whole time pose
what's in that head did you get a
masters dude I did not I literally I
don't even have an associate I do have
an associate I just can't even been able
to do anything with it that's like a
peasant degree everyone that just got
there is literally that just has it you
still suck that's okay y'all double down
on it that's good yeah that's right
we're all Pettit it's I didn't get any
degrees but I chose not to you go okay
my dick so if you haven't put the pieces
of the puzzle together JK has kind of
like funneled all of us and just kind of
like brought us all together so same
story I didn't want to be an actor I
didn't want to be an entertainment that
wasn't anything that was on my radar the
closest I got to wanting to be an actor
was wanting to be a model on TV for like
America's Next Top Model but that wasn't
because I wanted to be a model it was
just cuz I wanted to get out of my house
a good model like I wanted going on that
Victoria's Secret stages stomping like
that [ __ ] so bad yeah that was like the
closest I got to it I did get into like
the like the final round but then like
at that point you had to go to New York
or some [ __ ]
I can't RIT was years ago and my parents
are like [ __ ] no you're not doing that
like you're not ahem yeah like you're
not green crusher low quality females so
you're not doing that [ __ ] you've been
there I did the traditional route I got
my hair I got my bachelor yeah which is
way better than what it so I got my
bachelor's and step above peasant yeah a
little bit I'm [ __ ] I got it in
marketing I ended up in finance like
like Jess was saying it was the [ __ ]
worst time of my life that my life was
just like so predictable it was just
mundane and I'm like [ __ ] this sucks
money was good I was living on my own
but it was just the shitty [ __ ] of her I
meet Bart who owns
jakie films are just kidding films and
at that time it was just nothing it was
just like I think they probably had like
20,000 subscribers and at that time it's
like pretty decent because it's like
what Oh 9 and then they needed girls and
they needed help to like kind of revamp
the channel and I'm like well I know
some stuff for marketing like I do know
some Photoshop and that's kind of how I
started jumping into it more and the
more I saw you know the passion and just
the the the message that they had of
like unifying like minorities and for
them it was like Asian but for me I was
just like seeing it as like oh [ __ ]
minorities doing dope [ __ ] like that's
tight that speaks to me I like almost
immediately quit my job and luckily at
that time I had like 10k say I've done
my [ __ ] it I don't care if I don't know
where this food is coming from I mean
yeah my next meal is coming from or if I
can even make rent but I'm gonna do it I
was like the poorest that I've ever been
at that point I think that's a common
thread that we all like [ __ ] it let's
see what happens
yeah laid off my waitressing job and I
was like I don't want to get another
waitressing job like [ __ ] it [ __ ] it and
she just straight-up left Texas yeah
yeah that's a whole city's leap and the
net will catch you yeah sometimes I'm
just getting good flat it would know so
you know be careful be very careful it
don't do it don't do it yeah it was the
feet I was living off of that and I was
just like [ __ ] I'm so happy like this
is fun and I just stuck with it yeah and
then so all these other channels started
happening through JK so it started off
shaky films it's just sketch channel and
then from that it's them to like just
kidding party which at the time was like
a BTS channel and then it turned into
like a game channel and then from there
came JK news where we started bringing
in more guests and stuff and then I met
these girls well I met you before all of
that yeah and yeah through JK and used
like we started getting closer and I
just saw how bold and independent and
how different we all were but in our
differences we were all very similar in
that like we just didn't give a [ __ ]
about how the outside world perceived us
and I'm like oh my god I [ __ ] love
this like I love this
but girls cuz I just I just come across
females that just don't speak to me not
that they're like I don't like them or
whatever like I'm not that girl that's
like I don't like other girls it's more
like I mean I think I offended that girl
like that girl [ __ ] hates me now
because I I'm too crass alright cluster
today's yeah I have RBS I get in are
also like seven feet tall and super
intimidating yeah you look super hot
yeah what else am i well you know right
now I was telling my boy this in the car
this morning cuz he met like everyone
here and I was like I was like you know
what there's something wrong I was like
Gio is hot she's got a great body she's
a businesswoman she's [ __ ] she's a
mother she's like you've got a mom like
everything the whole package and I was
like something about it's crazy yeah
there's like there's no way this worked
on wrong with me all packaged there's a
[ __ ] ton that's that's what I did when I
first met you I was like this [ __ ] is
perfect yeah wake up o surpass these are
the Masters like that that took it from
like 120 to like 119 like life you're
checking up too many boxes here do but
no I'm not you are you're checking them
off good [ __ ] like I was saying the
other day like for the first few weeks
when I met Gio's like there's gotta be
something wrong [ __ ] because God is
fair you know yeah I have a leaky
butthole thumbs by the way I hate taking
showers I saw the thumbs I was like [ __ ]
yeah there is a there's a [ __ ] ton um
anyway yeah so then just kind of being
around their personality and their
energy you just like made me be just
more confident and and just be more open
and I'm like dude we gotta do this [ __ ]
we got to do something together like we
would dominate so here we are yeah yeah
hey bad all right Gina before I move on
let's have a honey book our sponsor here
that I've been using a lot lately
because I'm an irresponsible [ __ ] honey
book is great for creative people who
like me you like doing the creative side
but you hate like the tedious logistics
like invoices emails
like ash collecting cash and well I like
to count my cash but I don't like
collecting it in bookings and contracts
and stuff that's been me I've thought
that's my issue with starting a business
like I've always had the idea but I just
suck at doing a lot of little boring
things well honey book does that all in
one place you can also incorporate your
QuickBooks and Google suite and
MailChimp two in one place because [ __ ]
gets lost on her computer okay not that
you get lost but that this does
everything for you yeah and that's what
I need cuz I'm like I'm so unorganized
so if you're like me and you're
unorganized
unlike Gio she has everything spread out
for her but me and Beau's probably need
this a lot oh sorry ladies picture this
you're in the coffee shop with your cute
little MacBook and you've got your
you've got your like latte and you're
there on honey book just doing all your
business knocking everything out in 45
minutes now on to the next part no
seriously like it's so cute though it's
so cute you knock everything out just go
get Wi-Fi somewhere boom you're done for
the day on to creative projects in one
place so you not to open a ton of tabs
all the time yes also it's freaking cute
I'm sorry but like I love bougie looking
stuff yeah I just it just it's the whole
package yeah and right now for our
viewer's honey book is giving you guys
50% off for a free
5-0 here whole year 50% thing to lose so
just use our promo code b-tch for 50%
off your first year cut out the manager
do it yourself for 50% off dude and
payment is flexible and this promotion
applies whether you pay monthly or
annually that's amazing so make sure you
guys know you honey book calm and use
our code b tch for 50% off your first
year get paid faster and work smarter
with honey book calm and with our promo
code of course that's b tch without the
I alright and we're back Gina Gina heat
at Timmy girl Gina all right we started
in the summer of 1989 I was born on a
Tuesday afternoon
[Laughter]
the rapid so when I was that I've always
known that I've always wanted to be an
entertainment when I was four I saw
Cindy Crawford in a magazine I decided
that I want to be a mom for ya like I
want to be a model I asked my aunt
actually I said what what is she who's
that she's a model and I asked her what
it was she told me like models stand
around like braiding at baby rails like
[ __ ] yeah
touching out of high school I decided
that I never actually want to have to
wake up early to work for anyone I
didn't like the whole 9:00 to 5:00 I
wanted to kind of pursue my own thing
College was never my thing I never did a
single day in college so straight out of
high school I started working at
restaurants I was a waitress at like
three jobs at the time and then at 18
years old I became a go-go dancer in LA
so I was a go-go dancer for about seven
years and it went from like Dogo dancing
at the big nightclubs in LA - I got
scouted and I danced for like the
biggest festivals I still can't picture
you listening to music and yet alone
I've never seen no I can't imagine you
dancing some of the guys have seen
because they filmed in a club while I
was going dancing I was there that's
that so I go-go dance for like the
biggest festivals I did
insomniac event so I did like EDC and
all that and I was in love I was living
like the wild twenties life you know
what is that like like so instead of
like the college dorm studying for
finals life I was go-go dancing at
nightclubs I was waitressing at bars and
stuff like that and I was modeling on
the side and I was basically like it was
good at some times but if there were
times when I was like dirt poor yeah
that's why I worked three jobs and I
danced that night you know for those of
you don't know go-go dancing is not
stripping
we're atmosphere dancers at night oh
yeah we don't care like the girl in the
box that just keep moving yeah yeah
take their clothes off hmm but it was
like they should though I would have
gotten paid a lot more if I didn't but I
remember having to figure out which bill
to pay first and you know so I can eat
you know and then I remember having to
hit up the clubs like hey can you guys
book me this week because you know what
times I kind of hard right now I need to
pay for my bills because I was living on
my own since I was like 19 I moved out
and around 21 years old was when there
is a guy that I met when I was go-go
dancing at EDC he was one of the
character models there his name is Yoshi
sadar so he hit me up after EDC and he
was like hey we're shooting a miniseries
like a romance miniseries on YouTube but
our lead girl dropped out last minute I
met you at EDC but you seemed kind of
cool do you want to try it out and this
is like I've done like little small
local commercials here and there before
so I was like I mean I guess it'll be
fun to kind of learn what's a local
commercial and what was it that you did
like like it just sounds really funny
like a commercial for like eyelash
extensions or I was a model for like
those massage therapy instructional
video my god I can imagine them right
now and they're hella anything not a
born to me is that I modeled for like
Vietnamese magazine yeah that was a
pageant girl I did like a lot of
Vietnamese community stuff that was on
the Vietnamese TV channels right so I
was kind of used to being in front of
the camera already and so I told you oh
she I'm like yeah sure why not let's do
it so we shot the series and on one day
of shooting they brought in Joe and Bart
from JK as like a cameo and were you
there did you know she wasn't think you
just got your boobs is what I remember
yeah I had just got my boobs done like
he told me yeah two months before so I
wasn't even able to lift anything so if
we had to like shoot anything I'm like
sorry guys I can't lift it so that's
when I met Bart and Joe and the series
itself ended up not ever happening I
don't know what happened internally but
I can think I got a call from geo um a
while later she's like hey you don't
know me but I'm geo from JK and
the guys said they met you and they got
your information we need a hot asian
girl with big boobs for a video so I was
like I mean yeah I guess I can do that
and then I don't remember what videos
for but at that time also was when David
so first moved to LA and David and I
actually have a mutual my brother was
his friend in school so we became
friends on Facebook and I introduced
David to that crew and then eventually
David met you guys somehow I don't
remember how at a San Diego Film
Festival yeah so I already it was like
so David had me in one of his videos
already and then JK brought me in and
then somehow we all became one big
family and then I started getting hit up
more by JK like hey we need you for this
and that and then eventually I got
invited to JK news and I became a guest
on JK news at the same time I was trying
to get my youtube up and running but it
was weird for me too like I don't think
my life is that interesting
so you know go dance do you own the
big-ass [ __ ] snake you fire breathe
like you do it but like you like you
split your head open from like go car D
I don't even know what it was or
shooting a fro it was yeah TV you get
shot no I went shooting and then I in
the desert or something I was like you
like hotter cuz you know like guys
anyone like a [ __ ] has been shot at how
about our appreciation for life you know
what I mean I'll show you guys my
bullets carve you lucky enough okay yeah
I split my head open when I was driving
like a rhino ATV and I flipped it but so
the YouTube channel I'm on and off about
it but it wasn't I wasn't ever like
super passionate about it you know like
I got up there I think I had like 100 or
200 thousand but I never really followed
through because I was never in love with
it and then so a couple of years ago the
one thing that I know best when was
since I was a kid is playing video games
it's been my huge passion since I was a
child like it took me out of my like
rough home and I would play games and
would you know take my mind off my
issues at home right so um my friends
were like dude why don't you start
streaming video games and I'm like I
don't know about that it's so any
has to do logistics like paperwork
hardware and stuff like that just I
didn't like it
but I got picked up by a company they're
like why don't we build you a computer
will sponsor you and why don't you start
streaming and then I figured all right
it's what I do every day anyways I spent
hours playing video games at home why
not get paid for it so I started
streaming on Twitch and I got partnered
literally five minutes after my first
stream yeah which is really hard to do
for a lot of like my partner it is
insane she has a master's in gaming I
have a doctorate gaming so now I stream
full time I a Facebook headhunted me and
signed me a contract on to their
streaming platform so I stream full time
and that's like my main thing I can't be
any happier just doing my favorite thing
just playing games all day getting paid
for it talking to my fans but I always
stuck with JK the whole time like I've
been filming with you guys for what like
seven eight years now it's been a minute
yeah and then I found this group of
girls which is really weird because I've
always had like I I really do keep to
myself
and I have maybe like one or two friends
that I really keep close that I barely
see them at all same right yeah
with JK I see them so often and it was
funny it was hard for me to accept that
I was a part of the JK family I had the
longest time like I was with them for
like six years before like one day
they're like hey do you want to come
with us to our Japan trip and I was like
you're you're like a company trip yeah
it was a trip they're like yeah you're
part of the family I was like because I
always saw them as I go what agree I did
the same when you're inviting me to
Vegas yeah yeah it seemed yeah cuz it
was like this huge channel you guys have
been around like I watched him when else
I think you want to be my friend yeah
why did you make us sound old as [ __ ] I
mean I watched him when I was in high
seas yo you're really old like a
thousand look good
[Applause]
oh no Amazon I like it she throws you
looking under the bus and she picked me
up I saw Geo one day without makeup
Oh stairs it's not about so they they
hit me up to go to Japan I was like holy
[ __ ] like I'm part of this family and
then like they're telling these things
about themselves and I'm just like like
I felt like it out like a stranger in
your group like really cuz like you guys
have been together for so long I feel
like and then and then after the Japan
trip you guys invited me to Vegas I was
like oh my god this is real you know and
then so I started going to like their
houses for [ __ ] barbecues and then
for a while I still felt like I was a
stranger but then like after a while
especially the girls group and
everything they put me in the girls
group and we're talking about everything
and I was group the host base husband
okay
yeah and I start learning like Tiffany
started opening up we started like
Tiffany start hanging out with were we
starting up because we would go to these
events together and I was like oh [ __ ]
my real friend Jay Caleb yeah you know
like we sees each other outside of work
yeah it's real now and then then the
group came out and then I started
learning more and more about everyone
during trips and stuff and that's why I
love the trips cuz we get to like hang
out really get to know each other and
then I realize like this is my family
like I have a group of girls like I used
to see pictures of girls in a group
together kind of Vegas yeah I feel about
this girl's group I've never had like a
group of girlfriends like yeah it was
hard to pick bridesmaids cuz I was just
like I have two high school friends that
was my issue like yeah married I don't
know who the [ __ ] like I'm gonna have
just an empty wedding yeah and now it's
just like I have these girls and I think
the one thing that's solidified my
friendship with these girls was I told
TIFF and Gio this huge secret a couple
years ago and I have a su I assume that
when you tell someone the secret they
tell us their significant others right
and then later on I opened up about it
to Barton and aromatic Bart and a that's
apart and then Joe whatever to and
whatever and I told him about it's like
what really I'll say wait the girls
didn't tell you they're like no and then
Tiffany look no ain't no rat yeah no
virata's a old Walt's spell book no Gio
and two Flicka me they're like known if
he tells us see we're not going to
anyone Oh Dan these are some real
[ __ ] so that like solidified my
friendship with them I was like okay I'm
in this is my family and here we are at
this podcast yeah Here I am playing
video games till 3 in the morning and
then filming a podcast being here at 10
a of [ __ ] on one okay I'm tired all
right baby let's go baby baby why did
you hit the ball already better have a
mass okay so we're doing like origins
story
yeah yeah you just catching up you the
last person off the bus hello everyone
my name is Bo's Bo's
I am [ __ ] annoying okay but no like I
think we had like a pretty even
distribution of like nobody wanted to be
in an entertainment I didn't want to be
entertained me either but like because
I'm an only child and I just like take
attention it just kept happening but
actually no [ __ ] I wanted to be in
music when I was younger like I was what
kind like dude I was mad depressed so
like I would like do emo no I was like
six dawg oh six oh hell yes like an even
so much so that like I I think I'd like
Sixers no it was like maybe like seven
or eight I used to play the piano and
for like one of those talent
competitions in elementary school I
wrote this really gorgeous piano
composition it was this [ __ ] was called
slowly with dead oh wait a minute you
know I could do [ __ ] at six and you
think you're really really good at it no
I still I still have the tape of it and
it was really but this is what happened
so we submitted it and I immediately got
thrown out of the competition because
they said there's no way that a child
like did this this and so for me that
[ __ ] hurt because it was like you
like doing this thing but you didn't do
this like it just goes full stop look at
that teacher let's go jump it's like the
whole school or whatever so whoever was
doing the thing so like there was that
[ __ ] and then one day I was like singing
a song and somebody told me to shut up
and then I was like I don't ever want to
do music again Mike so like that's that
was like I always wanted to do music and
it's still like indie but like I'm gonna
do it so I can we gotta talk yes
wait maybe not this time but we're gonna
talk about that I feel like you should
write and perform the jingle for our
stream when we were four oh my gosh that
would be that would be funny but yeah so
like I kept like I kept like low-key
doing entertainment [ __ ] and just I
don't know I'm like my mom would throw
me and stuff because like I just have a
big personality but so I don't know I
just kind of moved through life I
graduated at sixteen cuz I got like
thrown out of three different schools
where did you grow up good Virginia okay
yeah yeah Virginia I got kicked out of
three schools and so finally at the
fourth one
they had like an online program so I
strapped the [ __ ] in graduated at 16 I
started a business
I was out this bit what kind of business
I was doing promotions for clubs I was
the only person I was like a child of
the Internet I grew up playing video
games too so like I was making like
flyers and I was the only person making
flyers in the area I went to this DJ and
I told him I was like hey man cuz I did
web design for like five or six years I
was like hey dude I'll make you three
flyers for free and then after that you
have to pay me cuz I had to get my foot
in the door somehow
music yeah he was like smart okay cool
and so I did one two three and then on
the fourth one he just sent me an email
with their quest I was like yeah I got
you but this time it's $50 and so then I
started picking up every [ __ ] club in
the area I was doing everything from
like promotion to like where do I put
these flyers how do we recap it like and
I was like meeting with like Club
managers and like talking about like
okay what do you want to do for sexy
schoolgirl night and all this [ __ ] but
then I started working in restaurants
that was the [ __ ] I love working
restaurants it's like fast life hella
trash you get drunk every night shit's
tight and then so I'm getting to like
how I got here you know you just got
blow through this [ __ ] so like Gina I
grew up playing video games
I started streaming on Twitch let me be
clear
I I played like League of Legends mostly
legal a nerd I don't know what that
means that if I hit level 6 I'm going to
skull [ __ ] anyone and so I wanted to
publicly put that on the internet like I
was I was I was pretty [ __ ] good at
this game at the time and in my head I
was like a level Tim but I was more like
a level seven like good at this that's
pretty good yeah I think it's pretty
good and like so I I hopped on the
website
I just started like live-streaming me
playing video games and it was just this
really angry black woman like it was
like I think I was like Platt like Platt
won in League of Legends so like I did
pretty yeah I did pretty good and so I
started streaming things are going great
like you make hella money doing it but
after about three years my stream
started plateauing and I told my parents
I was like okay if if things keep
plateauing because I keep mindful of
that stuff like there's a pattern with
everything I'm not gonna wait for the
next big hit I was like if things keep
plateauing I will go back to college and
finish it out
so things are going okay but then one
day I get like this dude he comes in my
chat and he's like hey hey Bo's I really
like your stream do you have like a
business email I don't like this is a
troll I was like [ __ ] off nerd I just
like I'd basically ignored him and so
then the next day I get a tweet from
this guy who like has like a legitimate
profile he's like an older dude and he's
like hey Bo's try to get in touch the
last night do you have a business email
for me and I was like okay it's like
give him my business email and he was
like hey I want to audition you for this
thing like do you have some time to talk
I just want to know your situation so
this dude called me from a Beverly Hills
number and I'm like Hello you know and
so he talks to me about this thing says
that it's like furthest I'll be a gawd
ition he's like would you be willing to
relocate to Los Angeles you'll have to
like do this we'll go through a bunch of
interviews like da-da-da-da-da and I it
was just so out of left field you know
and and so I took the interview and I
found out that it was for Smosh so I did
like my first interview like the phone
interview then I did a Skype interview
then I did another Skype interview then
I did a Skype interview with the whole
cast and I was just like boom boom boom
and they had a big pool of like 50
people and they were only gonna pick two
or three and so I I pass everything they
fly me out to go meet the cast and do
like a 30 day like filming with them see
if I get along with everything and I we
did a Smosh winter games and then at the
end of it this my boss is like he sits
me down the room he's like all right
we're gonna offer you a contract and
like I would like I thought I was gonna
[ __ ] cry like I was so happy because
like you know everyone beats themselves
up and they think like oh I didn't make
it I didn't do good whatever he was like
we're gonna offer you a contract and
then my whole [ __ ] life changed you
know like it really did and
you know I had my ups and downs there
but like definitely forever grateful for
that experience like who gets to move
out to LA with a [ __ ] salary and a
job where you get to travel the country
and play video games
[ __ ] sick but that's where I met
y'all I think I met I think I just met
TIFF yeah that's Smosh we were I mean
with Smosh we did like a go I was on
maternity maternity leave yeah it was me
Julia Joe I think that's it yeah yeah so
I met them on set and like we were like
mad chill and like I don't even know how
it happened were you just one day like
hey do you want to oh no I wasn't even
involved with that I think it was I
don't even know who it was I don't
remember who hit me up but I was like
hell yeah I want to come back and now I
was for that yeah I think it was Julia
she might have I think it might have
been Julia yeah but like then I just
started like shooting with JK news and
[ __ ] and like after like the third or
fourth time David was like he's like the
loss of JK news member and so well dude
it was but I mean like it was it felt
good it felt like and I feel like you
know JK news has gotten a lot of
publicity for like these people are real
and they are exactly who they say they
are like you know Theo said that on Joe
Rogan's podcast while it go in like it's
[ __ ] true like as soon as we turn
these cameras off and we turn the mics
off it's the same [ __ ] like we get a
little quieter we have our down time but
it's the same [ __ ] and like I love
that I'm all about it so you know I'm
down to ride yeah I work full-time but
I'm still like down to shoot this
podcast and like you can just hang out
with everyone you know yeah so Bose was
like our most recent addition she's the
newest one she had our first she had her
first JK trip with us in Vegas and last
one literally two days of TIFF and I
crying yes we bonded so much it was
amazing I love Sam and I got to be
roommates with her and it was just so
much fun that was that was the best yeah
we were like perfect together we would
like sit on our bed and just be on
reddit together yeah you in the morning
my favorite part was like at one point
with Jeana and I were just on our phones
and we're like you wanna get a bottle of
wine and get drunk
you all get drunk
alright bucket and then all three of us
shared a bottle of wine I don't remember
that invitation you guys yeah y'all
three were supposed to leave we were
fighting
why we invited two I was there all right
all right I got it
so what made you guys wanna jump in on a
podcast cuz I remember I approached you
guys and I was nervous as [ __ ] right
because I respect all of you guys
individually and I see you guys as like
like as my equals you know what I mean
not to say that I don't see a lot of
people as my equals but I just don't
like a lot of people real honest [ __ ]
yeah I'm just like a very introverted
person and and I was so nervous to
approach you guys with this idea because
like I didn't want you guys to be like
[ __ ] no like you with me like [ __ ] no so
I was just like hey you guys like like I
love the conversation that we have like
everyone's so raw so open so honest like
why don't we bring this to the public
because I remember being in this
host-based chat and I was just like whoa
like this is so much information I wish
I would have known growing up yeah you
know something as simple as like even
like a period conversation which Nikki
was like so in the beginning before we
shot this podcast I'm like alright guys
what are your boundaries Nikki's like I
don't have any just let's not talk about
I don't think peer you talk so if you
guys are going for be a jokes out talk
about like real minstrel stuff but like
might help people and real minstrels
like you know we're talking about how
like we couldn't figure out to put in a
tampon and that's like actually some
[ __ ] they okay so [ __ ] like that I
couldn't think of a fast any of us have
like any one liners for let's how are
you mark my men okay I take my blood
okay we don't free to roll out of the
know so I remember hearing these things
in these topics that you guys were
talking about and the advice that people
would bring in chiming it like chiming
into the conversation and I was like
holy [ __ ] like this is so tight like
like where were you guys when I was
growing up you know and I felt like the
advice that you guys guys gave was very
wholesome and very genuine and very
honest like if it was something where
one of the girls needed to get checked a
little bit or it wasn't like no like
this is a very like this did not happen
at all but like no you know what like I
feel kind of fat and like though the
girls are probably like yeah you can
lose a little bit weight like it gets to
that point and I was just like dude I
appreciate that because I've just never
experienced such real caring loving
group so when I saw all of that and how
different we all were I was like dude we
got to bring this to the public so I'm
sure there's so many other little Gio's
out there that are like I'm lost like I
don't have this group I I want to learn
from a group like this you know or or
like see how they [ __ ] up and see how
I can avoid [ __ ] up but what made you
guys go like yeah I'm down for that
same thing like not having any
girlfriends and then being part of a
girl's group for the first time ever
where I felt not crazy
I always felt crazy I always felt like
because I had my boyfriend's I've always
been my best friends and that's it you
know like I have them and they don't
understand when I have like hormones and
emotions from hormones and stuff like
that so I just like used to keep it to
myself like I'm just crazy and it's not
to be talked about and when we joined
the girl group and we were able to be
open about that craziness and everyone
was like me too I felt not alone for the
first time in my [ __ ] life and it was
so refreshing and I wish that I had that
earlier in my life
where's the cry glasses are you crying
how I got here is like Jill I don't even
know if Gia's gonna like kill me or
anything but know I miss more so like
alright I'm on the couch I'm on the
couch with my man and like you know we
we were we were about to start hooking
up we were having a sexy time I'm like
crawling all around
yeah like we're about to get like nasty
and it's that slow kind of nasty like
you know that starts up real slow and
and my phone keeps buzzing but I'm just
feel like no in like and then like we're
going on for like five minutes and my
phone and then finally he's like [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] yeah so I'm like not as
cool and so finally like I get off him
I'm like I and I look at this and I just
start scrolling through and y'all were
all talking [ __ ] and I was like I gotta
do a podcast again yeah I'm down and
then I was like dude delicately the
phase you know yeah I'm like all that
[ __ ] in the beginning I think I started
I decided to jump on the podcast because
well I mean the weird thing is I was
never I never bought into this whole
podcast thing like everyone had a
podcast like yeah there's too many of
them because everyone is start popping
about nowhere right but I realized well
one I want an excuse and a reason to
spend more time with the girls like I
want to lean oh that's honestly why I
said yes yeah right like I want more
reasons to hang out - guys I'm bond with
you guys and grow stronger like our
relationship stronger horse that's
[ __ ] serious girl so and so that was
the main thing but then also when I
thought about it I realized that yeah
like when I was younger I was the only
child in the house full of adults and
there was no older sister there was no
one to teach me about what was going on
like what the problems that I had and
stuff like that and I realized that I
ultimately what I want a Liz podcast is
entertainment but also to be the bigger
sister that our viewers need to teach
them things that they that we thought or
that we wish that we knew back then and
to guide them through really terrible
things
and the one thing that reminds me of it
is that I did I used to do like meet and
greets I'm used to fly over and do meet
and greets and there was this one girl
that I did to meet & Greets in my
hometown this one girl came to both of
them and each time she came to me she
would like shoot free she would cry and
be like I love you so much you know your
you and your stuff get me through
terrible things in my life I'm going
through so much and you know I look up
to you and you inspire me and it gets me
through my heartis days and then like
seeing her at car like that beat me I
saw some sort of familiarity in that
crime like I know that cry and I know
what that is and so that's why that was
you know another reason why I decided to
jump on the podcast because I want to
talk about the things that other people
are free to talk about I want to talk
about things that kids are teenagers and
stuff are afraid to come out to talk
about and hopefully they can find some
sort of strength and inspiration in us
to get through their hard times and grow
like how we did through our hard times
and maybe we can be their family - yeah
that's honestly like why so for me it's
I do think about little Tiff's and like
if she had this group of friends like
where would she be now but I guess for
me it's harder to place myself in a
position where like I'm giving myself to
responsibility for other people so I try
not to get into that headspace because
then I'll get really into my own head
but for me the main reason why I wanted
to do this podcast is to spend more time
with you girls because I really do feel
like yes we're close and in that chat
but it's like face-to-face interaction
for me is it's more important so that is
the main reason why I'm like yeah I'm
down for this beause again what did you
do something I didn't my bodily function
I don't know when to pull away so I'm
like every time I speak no I have great
ears oh the headphones yeah responds to
you hi Brooks but yeah so yeah and then
I also like right now currently in my
life this moment like I I feel like I
just really need something like this and
where's this guy Greg glasses father
all right there it's well-rounded but
yeah like I really really like the
current TIF really needs this group like
bad word
so people to stand next to yeah it's
such a well-rounded group of girls from
all different walks of life we have
mothers we have wives we have single
ladies you know like we have like
unmarried we have like college people
have tea mom yeah of Teen Mom what am I
am I just unmarried oh good I mean it
was like secure ways anyway look I mean
she was a company woman yeah like
business women we have like you know
it's such a huge like it's a hodgepodge
of all different walks of life and I
feel like every like viewers can find a
little bit of themselves in each and
every one of like the Spice Girls tired
okay Jess last for you I think that's a
culmination of all of those but I feel
like um I don't know if this is true but
I feel like I was one of the first
people that you brought it up to we
gather in the class and for me I think
it was surprising that I would be
invited to it because I don't see myself
as entertaining or anyone would even
want to hear something funny and you're
so who like your your delivery of the
[ __ ] that you'd be probably softened
it's just so dry I [ __ ] love it it's
like you don't say much but when you do
yeah you're white so this is like
perfect like if we get pulled over
you're sitting in the front seat can I
see your badge number officer I would
never say I'm the Becky I like but in a
good way like I'll talk to the manager
I'll figure yeah no I think I was just
surprised that I was seen as someone
worthy to be like on an entertainment
like show so I was like [ __ ] I'll do it
and then I started thinking more like
I'm just in the same boat like didn't
ever have a huge group I always had a
couple friends but I think a lot of
people nowadays the way social media is
set
and the way people's lives are
everyone's just so alone people feel
like more separated there's not much of
a community anymore so I know that I
feel better when I listen to a podcast
like if I'm alone all day and like I
have a bunch of errands to run I don't
get to really see people but I get to
like listen to a podcast and feel like
I'm still interacting with someone and
it brightens my day so I just felt like
contributing to that for someone else
would mean a lot to me so that's why I
did it
I can love this this is so dope and you
guys trust me when I say this I'm not
like trying to sell you some [ __ ] but
like we're clearly doing it for selfish
reasons here so you know that that
shit's gonna be very genuine because
it's like we're doing it really for
ourselves because we're enjoying it and
you so happen to have like this
invitation to just kind of be a fly on
the wall and I think it's a lot of fun
and the few topics that we're gonna not
the few but the next videos that we're
gonna be talking about gonna be really
dope topics like tick sizes and we're
gonna be talking about like how to deal
with the breakup and sliding into DMS
and how to talk to women yeah we need to
teach y'all how to slide into the m's
yeah yeah we yeah we really do yeah the
topics are gonna be anything and
everything with life and and love and
sex and relationships
and work and being being young 20s being
in your 30s like I'm 35 I'm gonna be
thirty Six's years until like in other
months okay I turned 30 in November 1830
next month oh I turned 30 in like three
years
but yeah trust me when I say this
podcast is gonna be sick as [ __ ] and you
don't want to miss anything and yeah I
think we're reaching the end of our
podcast here y'all our first ever
I think lo [ __ ] thanks for getting to
know was yes listening hopefully
hopefully we didn't scare you away and
you guys want to hear more from us
hopefully you found your favorite if
you're sounding needy guys a challenge
that by the end of the third episode you
have to pick your favorite you might
have somebody that right now you're like
oh I I'm most like this person you got
to give it three episodes till you pick
your favorite and then but like don't
tell us yeah we're gonna creep merge
with our face on it and then just buy
that in completely unrelated news giving
out free hand jobs from my vote okay
she's got really soft scent softest Wow
I heard that Ruffy is do better on the
dinosaur dinosaur paws are like the
women hands I know yours are like
androgynous yes literally has a little
dinosaur potty like a lesbian
like close your eyes picture Barney's
hand it's Jess's dinosaur paws I can see
you right for like bear paws in the
world holy [ __ ] alright y'all so before
I head out I want to say a special
thanks to our sponsors thanks again to
third love and honey book so for 50% off
your perfect bra yeah the team go to
third love calm / [ __ ] that's b tch all
right so it's b tch b tch yo I you know
I don't curse yeah we don't wanna do
that
and then for 50% off your first year
that's the first year come on yo of a
honey book go to honey book calm and use
promo code b tch get paid faster and
work smarter with promo code B tc8 ebook
50% off that's a good deal right yeah
yeah
and then lastly oh and shout out to
HyperX providing these awesome
peripherals we have our headsets
thank you so much we're standing by my
side for my stream use our podcast Thank
You HyperX nice thank you and Bob it is
good bye [ __ ]